uh dr henderson
are you happy with the pro prospect of
uh all nhs staff being compelled to have
two jabs or being dismissed that as
we're reading this morning
um so that's not something that i would
um be giving a uh anything other than a
personal opinion at the moment we would
like staff to be vaccinated because we
know that that will give them protection
and that we've see we've seen during the
waves that um
health care workers are very much in the
front line of the risks as well as the
treatment of the pandemic so yes i'm
keen that people are
getting vaccinated and that needs to be
clear to them and also to be honest
getting the booster because actually
that's the next layer is getting a
booster as well so
you know personally i would be saying to
everybody think very very carefully
about not doing this because this puts
your health at risk and therefore then
additionally puts your patients at risk
so as a professional uh
view of this would be to get vaccinated
i ask i ask that because of course
anything that puts extra pressure
on the department where you and your
colleagues work
of course could tip us over the edge
do you think that emergency departments
given the situation as it is now and
what we know are going to be able to
cope this winter
we're already already struggling to cope
it's this is not something that's coming
in the next you know couple of months
we're already in a terrible place where
we have got large queues of ambulances
with vulnerable people waiting in those
ambulances to be offloaded into
departments and other patients at home
waiting to be picked up by the ambulance
that's the thing that really worries me
that these are patients who've not yet
received treatment that we don't
necessarily know what's wrong with them
that we're really struggling to get into
our healthcare facilities to then work
out what we need to do that's the real
worry from my point of view and we're
already in that situation
what do you need to alleviate the
problem
we need to have beds so the biggest
problem is exit block both from an
emergency department into hospital wards
and from hospital wards back out into
the community so we need to be able to
get all patients who are fit to not be
in hospital
back out so the primary thing that we
need is to establish enough space in
community facilities or enough community
support so patients can be in their own
homes so that we don't have patients in
hospital who could be being cared for in
a different environment that then works
itself back towards the front line so
that instead of patients being stuck in
emergency departments what we call exit
block from from the emergency department
we can get them out of the department
and we can get new patients into our
cubicles it's a whole system problem
which happens to be bottlenecked in the
emergency department and therefore very
visible on the ambulance ramp
if nothing changes
can you talk to us about the seriousness
of this i mean is this
an inconvenience or are we seeing
people at risk of essentially dying
because uh the system is blocked up
the system is incredibly busy at the
moment when we're already ready reaching
a point where 999 ambulance call
handling is delayed so it's you don't
get an immediate answer to the phone
when you ring up 999 it takes time to
get an ambulance that push puts patients
at risk because you don't know what's
wrong with them you don't know what is
on the end of the phone is it some a
patient who needs care immediately as a
you know blue light ambulance or is it
somebody who can afford to wait 20 30 40
minutes um before they're reached but
the same is true on the ambulance ramp
unless we can get patients in and
actually assess them so that is risk of
real patient harm and patients dying so
it actually really matters this is not
about an inconvenience this is not about
being patient because of a long wait
this is about people who could come to
significant harm if we're not getting
the care to them that they need because
there's just so many people in the
system you can't spot the needle in the
haystack
one of the issues which
seems to have arisen is the question of
whether people can go to
their gps or not and get face-to-face
consultation if they can't they turn up
an a and e
um
do you think that there is any
issue
with that and
might you need to say to your gp
colleagues that it's time for them
to see more people face to face as the
secretary of state seems to be
suggesting
primary care is under enormous pressure
as well but the patients that we're
really worried about in the emergency
care system are not patients who are
getting or needing necessarily a gp
appointment they're they're sickest
patients we're most worried about the
most vulnerable patients and those are
the patients who are coming in by
ambulance by and large rather than it
being an issue with primary care
patients yes we get we get stories of
patients who've tried to get in touch
with primary care and then maybe have
come to us but that's not the main
pressure the main pressure is people who
need admission and not having a bed for
them to get to that's where our problems
lie in is in exit block rather than just
the volume
um i i'm not going to invite you to be
overly dramatic uh dr henderson but
everything you have told me this morning
adds up to
one
uh simple statement
that it looks and sounds like and feels
like that maybe people who are dying
today
because of the crisis that you and your
members are uh facing
we we know that crowding is harmful to
patients
we were crowded in emergency departments
pre-pandemic you said at the beginning
of this it's winter another winter
crisis you know what's new i mean sadly
that is true
we didn't go into the pandemic in a
great place in emergency care we didn't
have enough beds then the problem is
that things are worse at the moment so
we need everybody to be as careful with
the health care resources as they
possibly can be and try and minimize the
need for health care resources so if
we've got 8 000 patients in hospital who
are suffering covet if we didn't have
those patients that would be another 8
000 beds in the system so every bed that
gets filled by a patient with covert in
a sense is in a hospital bed with a
potentially avoidable disease and that's
what we need people to focus on if we
want to get through the elective backlog
everybody will know somebody who's on
that list we won't be able to do that
unless we've got the beds to put those
patients in so if we can get covert
levels down if we can make sure that the
vulnerable don't get infected and then
need hospital care if we can make sure
that we don't have people who are
severely ill because they catch it when
they're unvaccinated
all of that will help we're all in this
together to try and make it better